Is the early buzz for "Oppenheimer" a sign
of a serious breakthrough, or is it a dud?
In their early reviews, critics are basking
in the glow of what might just be a masterpiece.
J. Robert Oppenheimer changed the world as
we know it when he led The Manhattan Project
to develop the atomic bomb, and his story
is on its way to the silver screen.
Since its announcement, the biopic "Oppenheimer"
has been the talk of the cinematic world,
and for good reason.
With Christopher Nolan in the director's chair,
Ludwig Göransson responsible for the musical
score, and a stellar cast — led by "Peaky
Blinders" favorite and frequent Nolan collaborator
Cillian Murphy — the talent involved alone
seemed to set up the historical drama for success.
There's also a considerable amount of pre-release
hype for "Oppenheimer," thanks in part to
its shared premiere date with director Greta
Gerwig's "Barbie."
The excitement for double features of the
two seeming polar-opposite films has been
palpable, to say the least.
It's a perhaps improbable reason for such
positive word of mouth, but it's working.
"More than 20,000 people have already bought
tickets to see both movies on the same day."
There's also the matter of what critics who
saw it early are saying.
"Oppenheimer" held its world premiere in Paris
on July 11, and soon after, early thoughts
flooded Twitter.
Based on those early reviews, it looks like
Nolan has hit yet another cinematic home run.
After describing "Oppenheimer" as "fearsome,"
Vulture's Bilge Ebiri called it,
"A relentlessly paced, insanely detailed,
intricate historical drama that builds and
builds and builds until Nolan brings the hammer
down in the most astonishing, shattering way."
The Sunday Times' Jonathan Dean also gave
"Oppenheimer" a glowing review, specifically
touting the film's tension and the acting
work of Murphy, Matt Damon, Robert Downey
Jr., and Alden Ehrenreich.
While also giving Murphy high marks, TotalFilm's
Matt Maytum added the scale, the sound, and
visuals were awe-inspiring.
Given the subject matter of "Oppenheimer,"
the development of the atomic bomb, it shouldn't
be too surprising that it's also a harrowing
watch.
"This is a matter of life and death."
GQ France's Adam Sanchez commented,
"Christopher Nolan wanders in the mind of
#Oppenheimer and transforms the ravages of
the past into worries for the world of tomorrow."
Sanchez also described the film as "an extraordinary
experience."
Likewise, The Telegraph's Robbie Collin said
he was moved to tears by the time the credits rolled.
Elsa Keslassy of Variety reported that audiences
were so impacted by the film that they stayed
at the Grand Rex Theater after it ended to
discuss and debate it.
Nolan has a pretty stellar track record as
a director.
An "Interstellar" one, even.
The "Dark Knight" trilogy, "Inception," "Memento,"
and even sometimes-overlooked efforts like
"The Prestige" all left moviegoers floored
in their time, amounting to one of the most
impressive filmographies of the modern era.
Despite how remarkable those efforts were,
some folks aren't afraid to call it early:
Of the films he's made over his career, "Oppenheimer"
is one of, if not, the absolute best Nolan
has ever directed.
Writer and producer Ben Mekler tweeted,
"#OPPENHEIMER may be Nolan's masterpiece."
He predicted that it will more than likely
be an Oscar contender down the road.
Jonathan Dean put "Oppenheimer" alongside
"Memento" and "The Prestige" in his personal
top three Nolan movies.
Simon Thompson of The Playlist wasn't afraid
to apply words like "perfect" and "impeccable"
to the feature and some of its key elements.
The countdown to the theatrical release of
"Oppenheimer" hits zero on July 21.